il y a eu un énorme tremblement de terre
aux nord-est du japon aujourd'hui la
centrale nucléaire de fukushima daiichi
est en situation critique
monsieur le président c'est extrêmement
grave
il y un avertissement de méga tsunami
[Musique]
si le courant n'est pas rétabli à temps
le coeur va fusionner ce serait une
catastrophe
il est nécessaire de relâcher un peu de
pression quelqu'un doit entrer dans le
bâtiment du réacteur contaminés le
niveau de radiation est élevé on doit
décider qui va le faire si vous êtes
prêt à vous porter volontaire
veillez lever la main oui si mais aussi
voyez les i moi aussi
ceux qui sont sur place risquent leur
vie
tel peut éclater à tout moment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis né ici et j'ai grandi ici je
ferai tout pour sauver cet endroit
championnat des pâtés de renault au
cours des vingt dernières années mes
potes et moi avons trouvé le moyen de
satisfaire ce besoin de conquête et
victoire de couronnement à jouer pour
cent mille dollars les mecs
le moment tant attendu est arrivé le
premier défi est une succession
d'épreuves qui comprend qu'elle cette
pastèque des bulles gonflables une
course de motos des fûts de bière à
descendre la traversée des anguilles
électriques pas de questions vous êtes
prêt à y aller
dites moi un truc qui pense qu'il sait
encore y faire pour brancher une fille
c'est tendu nous on sait réussir à les
emmener sur la piste et qu'elle vous
embarrasse pas des laxatifs
oh
préféré que tu me dises ya cinq ans tu
choisirais tu es plutôt couloir
qu'on fasse entrer le dragon quest
a abobo
c'est pour ça qu'on recommence ses jeux
serrés tout qu'on peut faire contre nous
à vie pour ce genre de souvenir son
oreille mais dans quel état de paix
d'amitié ne s'éteindra jamais
l'une de ces tranches dégâts
[Musique]
si maicon pas content juste un mec
déterminé peut anéantir l'humanité en
deux secondes
objet suspect
odéon patrouilles d'intervention
est acquis pour l'arrêter
et plus que nous
[Musique]
moi je suis prêt
on
c'est pourquoi je suis là maintenant
moi du fait que grâce aux aventures bug
jeanne cherhal borloo pas vraiment fan
d'une part et à la ronde
[Musique]
m
[Rires]
[Musique]
m
la chaîne la casse
[Musique]
strauss kahn
quels délais
[Musique]
c'est une question pour vous à l'iss
qu'est ce qui vous a convaincu de
réaliser chambre de 102
[Musique]
je crois que la seule raison valable
pour faire un film c'est un désir
irrépressible
[Musique]
vous êtes à guînes demande est pour
quand vous voyez plus quand j'ai lu le
script j'ai senti que j'avais pas le
choix faire ce film c'était une question
sur
oui et ne croyez pas les gens qui disent
qu'on peut tout avoir sans prendre aucun
risque
parce que c'est pas vrai
[Musique]
et il peut arriver que des personnes
pour même
de tuer
[Musique]
il peut arriver que les personnes qu'on
ait manqué ses pensées ça fait sans
doute partie rejet officiel qu que ça en
vaille la peine
tous
les ricains
vous estimez que ça en valait la peine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
samedi
discours
[Musique]
tu sais
mais tu sais
[Musique]
à genoux
coutu système audio
[Musique]
et tu sais